>> IF THERE WAS EVER A WEEK FOR
A DAN BONGINO FRIDAY NEWS
EXPLOSION, IT'S THIS WEEK.
OUR FAVORITE NEW YORK CITY COP
HERE TO BREAK DOWN EVERYTHING
THAT HAPPENED.
HE'S GOT A BRAND NEW BOOK,
EXONERATED, THE FAILED TAKEDOWN
BY PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP BY THE
SWAMP, OUTSTANDING.
GREAT BLUEPRINT.
>> WE LAY OUT THE BLUEPRINT.
THEY TRIED THIS SCAM BEFORE.
I DEEPLY APPRECIATE YOU
MENTIONING THE BOOK.
LET'S GET TO THE NEWS EXPLOSION,
THE FAVORITE SEGMENT OF THE
WEEK.
TWO STORIES THIS WEEK, BUT
REALLY THREE.
THERE IS A TIE FOR NUMBER ONE.
STAY TUNED, GIVE OUT THE SPECIAL
AWARD AT THE END.
WHO'S STORY NUMBER TWO?
HILLARY CLINTON, CORRUPTION
FIGHTER, TUCKER.
WARRIOR AGAINST CORRUPTION.
HILLARY CLINTON -- GET YOUR
BERRIES HERE.
HERE'S THE PENALTY FLAG, HILLARY
CLINTON, ILLEGAL PROCEDURE, 15
YARDS.
CORRUPTION FIGHTER?
DONALD TRUMP IS A CORRUPT HUMAN
TORNADO.
SO I DON'T LIKE WRITING NOTES
FOR THE SEGMENT.
URANIUM 1 PAY TO PLAY IN THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
THE UKRAINE SCANDALS, THE ROSE
LAW FIRM, SPYGATE, HILLARY, JUST
A NOTE, YOU MAY JUST WANT TO SIT
THIS ONE OUT.
I'M JUST SAYING.
HILLARY CLINTON, CORRUPTION
FIGHTER, WHO KNEW, RIGHT?
NOW WE HAVE A SPECIAL AWARD.
THE WINNER OF THE BEST DRAMATIC
RETELLING OF A DEMOCRAT'S FAKE
NEWS HOAX.
TWO CONTESTANTS.
ADAM SHIFT WHO REINVENTED THE
ENTIRE TRANSCRIPT IN THE UKRAINE
CALL AND TOLD A DIFFERENT STORY,
HYPERBOLIC STORY OF WHAT TRUMP
SAID TO THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
HE WAS GIFTING IN HIS RETELLING.
I WANT TO COMPLIMENT HIM ON HIS
SKILLS THERE.
THEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
DECIDED THEY WERE GOING TO GET
CREATIVE, THEIR OPINION SECTION,
AND THEY PUT OUT A TWEET WITH
THE STAR WARS SCROLL TELLING
WHAT THEY BELIEVE TO BE THE
TRUMP STORY OF CORRUPTION.
OF COURSE, THEY'RE A FAKE NEWS
STORY.
SO, TUCKER, I HAVE THE ENVELOPE.
WE HAVE A WINNER HERE.
>> WHO WINS?
>> IS THE TENSION BUILDING?
THE WINNER IS ADAM S CHIFT.
>> THIS IS AN INVITE TO MY
7-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER'S DINNER
PARTY.
WE HAVE A TROPHY.
HERE IT IS.
THIS IS MY DAUGHTER'S LACROSSE
TROPHY.